[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
okay so this is when i was uh
drinking a lot
like your eyes i was uh you know i was
at the bar
and you know drinking some beers
and uh it might have been a week night i
don't know
but i was there with some skater dudes i
don't know how good of friends uh
whatever yeah
um
bar closes
um and i'm like
and this is uh ramona had moved into uh
out out of the dorm oh she had her own
apartment she was living off campus yeah
and i knew she was off university so i'm
like dude she like lives right there
yeah so this is you know around two i go
there
unannounced
i remember she lived on the second floor
so i just you know i knocked
sound effects no answer
no answer yeah i do it again
[Music]
no answer yeah
but then this turns into my skateboard
truck
oh
you do
[Music]
i know i was drunk i was so wasted this
is in my mind oh booty call on you now
just craziness right
i didn't know this at the time
but
ramona had
she was living with her pregnant sister
and the pregnant sister's husband which
i didn't know he's probably in ufc right
now he knew some [ __ ]
so
i'm thinking
oh
ramona's going to answer the door but it
is some big japanese dude
i've never seen yeah
before you know it he ha he shucks me
down and has me in a [ __ ] body lock
and i'm like this and then what did you
say i go this doesn't concern you man
i was like this this doesn't deserve you
man
i was like i want to talk to ramona yeah
yeah
and i ended up going to jail
when's the last time you saw the
original rocky
oh my god no because i saw rocky too
i saw rocky too um the weak dad died but
the original
what now why
did jesus smell it did you smell it
did you smell it
did you smell it
you know what that's
what it is
it did i don't know what possessed you
to do that
sorry you know corn dog on a stick yeah
yeah
poo on a stick
dude you know what that smell like your
[ __ ] breath
your breath always smells like that no i
okay this is a good segment like it
releases certain things in your brain
serotonin levels yeah yeah and you have
to balance it and not play too much
because it's really bad for you is it
really porn so it's like porn
same thing you got it's video you guys
are it's video game porn i mean bobby is
literally jerking off to war zones it is
hours and hours
it's just you're masturbating with your
mind and not your penis it's just you
know in the pentagon dude you're right i
know but it's like it but what do we do
it's pen i mean what do we it's that
there's
[Laughter]
but you said something about blood
that's how i remember like hot blood i
said yeah you said yeah yeah you said
something about blood it wasn't bleeding
yeah but it just tasted like oh so you
went down on her you're very charitable
yeah that's actually pretty nice she
wasn't that bad
she wasn't that bad she was pretty
attractive
yeah she's great yeah
you guys aren't really into eating [ __ ]
both of you i mean why is it
you're not
no i just i'm not good at it i don't
think i just go you know
what was that yeah that's how you do it
right off the bat yeah so fast man
i'm not good at it will you do it
because i think that the good guys know
how to do the finger they could do that
and you know they know the hot spot
i don't know how to do any of that
it's just just
you know yeah it's a mess
what is it about us that we like we love
this is the thing we love the smell we
both we love smells we love we love no
not good smells bad smells bad smell
[Music]
oh
i've always been that way too you
remember in high school before my
matches like this yeah yeah it wasn't
this that i was
why did it what were you smelling it was
the salat the saliva from this then i go
like this and smell it no you would do
this first
watch what you're about to say
think about it i already know okay
i'm just telling you the truth okay okay
all right okay well this is eighth grade
ninth grade when i started wrestling in
sixth grade let me ask you something go
ahead before you
bit and smelled your thumb right were
you was your thumb
in a different area of your body
be honest i think you're missing a step
no no
yeah i think yeah i do you tell him
before wrestling match i would go like
this and jam it up my ass derek oliver
say it
[Laughter]
if you want me to tell you the story
he's gonna look like a fool
okay okay i'm gonna say this okay he's
feeling okay look at his face already if
he tells okay if he tells a story we're
gonna have a very big problem
why
okay all right i don't want to look make
him look like a fool but come on let him
tell the story who cares
drinking and using drugs
it's only fair flapping your arms
it's embarrassing all right tell them
what happened
that was the okay you know i told you
you know hey hold up andrew you know how
i told you that story of how proud i was
during that wrestling match
well this fight made me feel the
opposite
[Laughter]
so
there's this these kids i was friends
with his younger brother there's
this household derek oliver which was
his age
and david oliver i was friends with
david
they had a fight i don't know how
it progressed to this fight that they're
like meet me at the the yard above where
i live
at what time like 4 30 after school yeah
yeah right and everyone shows up
everyone shows up and he just got his
ass kicked
he was getting pounded my mom had to
save him
so thank god for my mom my mom happened
to drive by
and see the kids and she goes yeah
either you know like it was embarrassing
i was just like oh my god
bobby what went wrong what did you do in
the fight that was such a was such a
[ __ ] up
i didn't think that he would fight
oh yeah you were better this is the
reason why
this is why you can't judge a book by
its cover because
oliver was he wore speedos and was on
the diving
and he wasn't banned
[Laughter]
he beat your ass
[ __ ] you
i told you not to tell the story i
smoked you
smoked your ass it was true it was
promoted i don't know who promoted it
but everyone in the neighborhood yeah
yeah it was on top of the door
oliver right my brother's there and
everybody right yeah and dean doesn't he
you know i was kind of trying to i
didn't think he was going to fight me he
he fought you he [ __ ] hits me in the
face i [ __ ] you up dude and i bloodied
it
yeah i'm dizzy and he beat the [ __ ] out
of me yeah
just hitting my face a couple of times
and i did some like arms in the pants
i fell in the ground and then i i was
winded right and scared right and i
never picked time yeah again tell what
tell them the part where mom drives up
oh yeah then mom drives up wait
get in the car yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and i'm bleeding so my mom saved him
yeah yeah
i'm not the [ __ ] dude i'm sorry you
didn't try to help him out steve where
[Music]
i remember another time he got beat up
too the wood hills beat you up too yeah
scott what yeah yeah yeah
scott what he'll beat you up in front of
denny's
do you remember that story bob what
happened i don't remember that one just
beat him up
you're running your mouth in front of
denny's and scott woodhill popped you
yeah
yeah i just um you know the derrick i
remember the derek one because i
remember not being able to sleep for
like six months after that oh and i
remember just the way that i was just i
was
oh god i was just like you [ __ ] nerd
you're in band and you swim you know me
like swimming as a right and he's like
and i've been doing it for years
like just picking on this kid
he was a good kid i know i know you know
one day he just goes
all right buddy
you mean fourth you were a bully i mean
you were always
i was a bully the yard you know what i
mean
we knew what the yard was right 4 30 and
i go you [ __ ] little bit spit on him
yeah he was a bully man i show up at the
yard and i'm like yeah this guy's not
gonna
yeah i mean
and i walk up and the next thing i know
i'm just blacked out
out of breath right and he was just
beating the [ __ ] up in his arms laughing
my arms like this it was so embarrassing
and then just blood all over my face and
i hit my yeah
yeah oh my god in the car my mom just
not like drawing
imagine your mom went to because she
wanted to see the fight
i took no i took a snow a steak
and i just drilled a hole in it right
and i tried to squeak
and then i stuck it on my penis and i
tried to squeeze it together
right to give it friction right and it
kind of bent like this and it just
ripped apart
damn you have a strong headache i don't
know if this counts but um
when we lived in power we had a jacuzzi
yeah we [ __ ] a jet yeah
i uh i would when it got hot in there i
would stick uh do you i would i think a
lot of people do that it felt so good
yeah my dorm is literally right down the
street from where he was performing yeah
right down the street i lived at the
little dorm you know i was seeing a girl
god who's the girl scene oh gene yeah
gene yeah jean was like
like a paler white kind of yeah
yeah and then gene i don't even know her
friend's name but she was like a fat
latina woman okay
like pretty fat yeah fat
pretty fat really fat pretty fat yeah
yeah um
and then my friend brian from chicago
remember my friend brian we wrapped
together and stuff so we went to see him
and then i go
set up like maybe an after party in my
dorm room or
something oh no tell them we wanted to
take you to lunch yeah so my brother
that day so my brother's like yeah man
we're gonna go to a restaurant one of my
favorite restaurants in the whole world
like he class it up as if we were going
to morton's
right and and he's it's morning
steakhouse yeah he goes my tree
you know i mean like we're going to this
classy classy place yeah my [ __ ] yeah i
mean you're gonna love it dude la style
right
and he takes me to
mongolian barbecue
no mongolian wok
frozen beef in a bowl
right they weigh it but dude i was a
college student i didn't know you know
what i mean like i didn't know good
places i thought it wasn't gourmet
though it wasn't it was my interview it
was high end of me because i'd ate
wendy's every day yeah
[Music]
so thank you for that meal okay
okay i don't know it's kind of a farm no
i'll just tell you exactly what i ended
up doing okay well i painted a little
bit we're in the same room at night
we're in the same room we're in jean's
dorm room with we're in the girls dorm
room he's with this girl white girl jean
and i'm with the other one
okay okay and uh yeah yeah yeah and um
no condom no no no no you do it i did
work on them because you walked up to me
i was with jean and you go hey dude do
you have a there's condoms here
hey
and i go to the desk yeah and she had
him in the desk oh she did yeah and i
gave you one and i wore it yeah
i think you don't remember that i don't
remember i do but here's what here's
what i do remember okay okay
and this is where i'm probably going to
go to hell he was in and out of there so
fast not only that a year later well
hold up you didn't even complete the
story i want to get into the sexuality
of it why not because i don't if she's
listening i don't want her feelings
it's not right and it's probably
inaccurate so long ago yeah it's a long
time ago but here's where i was the
biggest [ __ ]
a year later i'm opening for paulie
at that same room yeah and i'm on stage
and i see she was sort of like front row
in the front row
and she's looking at me with these sweet
eyes
and when you where you walk off the
stage right is where are you you
literally walk by her
so i crushed i go good night right
and she i get off stage she grabs my arm
and i go like this get off me bobby
bobby
she grabbed me like that i go get off me
like that and i went to the green room
and i waited until everyone left the
club after paulie was done and then i
went out why why was that your instinct
you just don't touch me just embarrassed
no i killed your head
i know i just crushed
get off me
my first question to you
if you owned a liquor store
in l.a yeah
and
a black just a random black guy pissed
on your building
that's one thing yeah is it the same if
you saw lebron james pissing on your
building oh god
i'm i'm no i'm just asking a valid
question okay but there's a difference
let me just say right now i'm not going
with my argument don't yell at me i'm
get i'm telling you the opposite point
of view okay
for me
oh a random black guy's pissing on my
building oh [ __ ]
lebron james ah
i'm gonna get a photo
i'll be real it's [ __ ] lebron james
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]